auch wenn es durchaus weh tut liebe
zuschauer lassen sie uns noch einmal
über den politischen aschermittwoch
sprechen oder wie humor profis das
nennen die sachgrundlose besetzung ja ja
es ist ein beinharter job solche
auftritte vor betrunkenen das weiß ich
aus eigener erfahrung da lautet die
goldene regel für den humoristen
einfache kurze hauptsätze und ruhig das
schlüsselwort mehrfach einstreuen hier
so geht das bekommen arbeit leute arbeit
und nicht eine maßnahme arbeit und nicht
eine maßnahme arbeit kommen die leute
arbeit und arbeit
ich habe ich hatte kurz nicht zugehört
was kriegen die leute arbeit okay das
finde ich gut
nun aber zum aschermittwochs original in
passau beim csu event kam es zu einem
regelrechten eh klar weiß nicht ob sie
es gesehen haben hier markus söder
marschiert in die halle und das
orchester spielt den bayerischen
defiliermarsch
wir sind völlig zu recht schockiert
meine damen und herren
denn laut offiziellem staatlichen
hofprotokoll ist nun einmal der
bayerische defiliermarsch nur für den
amtierenden bayerischen
ministerpräsident vorbehalten aber ich
komme damit emotional zu recht vielen
dank moment jetzt geht es wieder
ansonsten gehört das low light des
aschermittwochs diese woche natürlich
wie immer der afg andre poggenburg hat
wieder einen rausgehauen
aber warum soll man da jetzt sendezeit
opfern für diesen ekelhaften
rassistischen scheiß nur so viel in
seiner rede kamen die worte türkische
gemeinde kameltreiber und kümmel händler
vor setzten sich das einfach im kopf
selber zusammen so schwer ist es nicht